you know I posted our actually my social
media team posted something that I say
over and over and over again that's
something I've said before they reposted
it on Twitter this week if you'll do
rich people stuff you get to be rich
people if you do poor people stuff
you're gonna be poor people if you're
rich people and you do poor people stuff
you become poor people if you're poor
people and you do rich people stuff you
become rich people and some idiot
left-wing socialist crazy leftist thing
pick that up and posted it and so I've
gotten like five thousand troll hate
tweets from left-wing socialist crazy
people
oh so if I go buy a brand-new Ferrari
and I rip people off from their pensions
I'll be rich is the response to that
tweet when obviously if you have half a
brain cell then what that tweetment was
find out what rich people are doing for
real and do that which by the way I can
tell you what they're doing they live on
less than they make they avoid debt and
that's how they became rich it wasn't
that they rip people off or raided a
pension fund or file bankruptcy 22 times
or all of your leftist crap are they
inherited money oh I can't inherit money
so how am I going to rich people stuff
you're a [ __ ] you're just a [ __ ]
I mean seriously but it the problem is
is that when people get to where they
are have you know Hope deferred proverbs
says makes the heart sick so if you're
26 or 36 or any six and you do not
believe deep down in your soul that
you're ever gonna win because you have
believed a worldview that says the
little man can't get ahead you're
trapped and the mean old what Evers are
out to get you an e or becomes your
spirit animal
oh it's bad it's always gonna be bad
and then someone presents to you the
idea that you actually are in control of
your destiny oh and you're responsible
for your destiny that really will piss
you off if you are living in a hopeless
situation and that's why I get leftist
crazies that are really really angry
with me because I present to them hope
and they don't believe there is any oh
and I present to them that is up to them
to do it by the way do you want to be
left as crazy to understand this you
could be a right crazy guy like an aunt
right nut burger okay you could be one
of those guys you know trying to live
off the grid and collect a munition you
know I mean if you're one of those nut
burgers you could be that and still what
you have is you've lost hope that you
are going to control your destiny and
this millionaire study proves that 90%
of America's millionaires are
first-generation rich 79% inherited 0 5%
inherited less than a hundred thousand
another 5% inherited less than two
hundred thousand and inherited it so
late in the process they were already
millionaires before they inherited any
money so the inherited the idea that you
inherited money it made you a
millionaire is an absolute fallacy it's
just factually wrong it's not where
millionaires come from now that's
something to think about
you got to think about okay am I in
charge of my destiny not a hundred
percent bad stuff happens to us I could
pull out a parking lot and get t-boned
and it's not my fault and that could
throw me off I don't get I don't get to
control that part but I control the
controllables I control the guy in my
mirror he's controllable that's called
self control it's part of being a
grown-up but what a rich people really
do do they really rip people off are
they really did you become rich by
raiding a pension fund or filing
bankruptcy ten times is that really
where wealth comes from see if you
really believe that line of garbage you
know and I think honestly I think it's
intellectually insincere to say you
believe it if you have if you have two
brain cells we
you have to look around and go that is
not where wealth comes from ripping
people off is not where wealth comes
from let me give an example okay
businesspeople are ripping people off
and that's how they beat those evil
businesspeople of course you're tweeting
on an Apple phone that you bought from a
bassinets person so you should think
about that when you're doing you [ __ ]
but anyway here's the thing here's what
happens with business
those who do a bad job and rip people
off people talk about it and don't go
back both so let's say this you go to a
car mechanic and your car's broken and
you go in and the guy rips you off he
does a horrible job he charges you too
much money fix doesn't even do the stuff
he said he was going to do and the car
still doesn't work do you go back only
if your parents are cousins
okay you really don't go back okay you
so he's not he's lost you as a customer
do you tell your kids and your friends
and your parents to go there to get
their car fixed no not unless you're
stupid you tell them to avoid the guy
because he's a ripoff artist so he
doesn't get any business from you or
anyone you know now I'm confused being a
crook how did he prosper only in your
hopeless left-wing crazy world did that
guy prosper it's it's mathematically
impossible for him to prosper ripping
people off now you might get a one-time
hit you might just completely steal ten
million dollars out of something and one
time rip somebody off but nobody goes
back for seconds with crooks except
stupid people I mean Bernie Madoff opens
up an investment firm how many of you
are gonna sign up think about it crooks
do not prosper
instead the guy fixes your car he does a
great job and he goes oh hey you know as
a 35 cent part it took me five minutes
no charge what do you do then you tell
everybody you know to get their car
fixed they're so honest good people are
the ones that prosper please don't think
otherwise it just makes you look stupid
it just makes you that and that skies
run the business same with the heat and
air company same with an ice-cream shop
I mean if you rip people off you don't
prosper why is this hard it's really not
hard